♪ ♪
>> Tucker: IT WASN'T SO LONG
AGO THAT A GUY FROM DALLAS,
TEXAS, CALLED ALEC STEIN STARTED
SHOWING UP IN CITY COUNCIL
MEETINGS ACROSS TEXAS, BUT
POLITICIANS NEVER PAID ATTENTION
TO HIM.
HE WAS A CITIZEN, BUT THEY WERE
NOT THAT INTERESTED.
HE ADOPTED THE ALTER EGO AND
BECAME A LOT MORE VALUABLE AND
IN THE PROCESS SHOWED US HOW
UNHINGED OUR OWN LEADERS HAVE
BECOME.
HERE'S ALEC STEIN AT EVERY
RECENT MEETING EXPLAINING WHY
MANDATORY VACCINATIONS ARE
ESSENTIAL.
>> WE'VE GOT TO MANDATE VACCINES
BECAUSE RIGHT NOW I AM LOSING
HOUSEKEEPERS LEFT AND RIGHT
BECAUSE LISTEN, EVERY TIME THEY
SEND A HOUSEKEEPER TO MY HOUSE
AND THEY TEST POSITIVE, I CAN'T
HAVE THEM WORK AROUND MY KIDS.
I HAVE TWO TRENDS KIDS IN MY
HOUSE AND THEY ARE VULNERABLE.
WE NEED MORE PEOPLE VACCINATED.
>> Tucker: THEY THOUGHT THAT
WAS REAL.
THEN THEY TRIED TO CONVINCE THE
CITY COUNCIL TO START WORLD WAR
III.
WATCH.
>> I AM A SERGEANT IN THE
UKRAINIAN FOREIGN LEGION.
I AM HERE TODAY TO RECRUIT TO
SOME OF YOU TO GO FIGHT IN WORLD
WAR III.
WHEN YOU JOIN UKRAINE'S FOREIGN
LEGION, WE ARE GOING TO TRAIN
YOU.
YOU DON'T EVEN NEED ANY
TRAINING.
WE ARE GOING TO TEACH YOU.
WE PREFER IF YOU DIDN'T HAVE
TRAINING.
WE WANT TO TEACH YOU YOUR GUN
SKILLS.
YOU ARE A COWARD AND I AM A
HERO.
THIS IS A HERO.
HE WOULD NEVER -- YOU WOULD
NEVER KNOW WHAT IT'S LIKE TO BE
PRESIDENT.
HE WILL NEVER KNOW.
HE WILL NEVER FIGHT AND YOU WILL
BE ON THE WRONG SIDE OF HISTORY
BUT ALL YOU HAVE TO DO IS SIGN
UP ON THIS FORM RIGHT NOW AND
YOU CAN GO FIGHT.
>> THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Tucker: [LAUGHS]
YOU CAN WATCH A LOT OF THOSE ON
YOUTUBE.
SPEND AN ENTIRE AFTERNOON
CHUCKLING AND LEARNING.
ALEC STEIN IS THE HOST OF
"CONSPIRACY CASTLE" AND WE ARE
HAPPY TO HAVE HIM.
ALEX STEIN COMMIT IS GREAT TO
BEAT YOU.
HOW DID YOU START DOING THIS.
>> DO SUCH A PLEASURE BUT LET ME
TELL YOU SOMETHING BAD WE ARE ON
CONSTANT MEDIA CONTROL BE IT I
SAID I WAS NOT GOING TO LET THEM
CONTROL MY LIFE BUT I WANT TO
START TALKING OF THESE
POLITICIANS.
AND I WAS DEAD SERIOUS AT FIRST,
AND THEY DISREGARDED ME.
THEY DIDN'T PAY ATTENTION.
THE CRAZIER I GOT, I REALIZE
THAT IS HOW YOU INVOKE A
RESPONSE BEAR THESE PEOPLE ARE
WHAT I CALL "NONPLAYABLE PLAYERS
IN THE VIDEO GAME LIFE."
THAT IS NOT THE CASE.
WHAT I'M TRYING TO DO IS PUT A
MIRROR UP TO THE MAINSTREAM
MEDIA AND SHOW WHAT THE
NARRATIVE IS AND HOW IDIOTIC IT
IS.
EVERYTHING I SAY IS JUST
REGURGITATED FOR I'M DON LEMON,
IDIOTS AT CNN.
IT'S PRETTY EASY WHAT.
>> Tucker: WHAT IS TRAUMA
BASED MIND CONTROL?
>> WHEN YOU TURN ON CNN, EVERY
SINGLE SECOND YOU ARE GOING TO
SEE -- THEY'RE GOING TO TRY TO
SCARE YOU.
THAT IS HOW THEY CONTROL YOU.
THEY WANT TO KEEP US IN
FIGHT OR FLIGHT.
THEY WANT EVERYBODY SCARED OUT
OF THEIR MIND SO THEY CAN MAKE A
DECISION.
SO WE CAN'T SEE THE BIG PICTURE
APPEARED WHAT HAPPENS IS WE HAVE
WHAT IS CALLED THE MOCKINGBIRD
MEDIA.
THEY ADMIT THE CIA -- YOU HAVE A
MEDIA THAT WILL SAY, HUNTER
BIDEN'S LAPTOP IS FAKE THAT THEY
HAD TO COME OUT AND SAY OH, NO,
THAT'S REAL.
THEY ARE GOING TO GIVE US THE
CRACK PIPE ALL DAY LONG, BUT
THESE PEOPLE DON'T CARE.
LOOK AT BROWN JACKSON IS ABOUT
TO BE NOMINATED INTO THE
SUPREME COURT.
NONE OF THIS IS DONE ON
ACCIDENT.
IT IS A PURPOSEFUL
DESTABILIZATION OF THE MIDDLE
CLASS.
THAT IS WHAT I AM.
I'M A MIDDLE-CLASS PERSON TRYING
TO SAVE IT.
I'M NOT HERE TO VIRTUE SIGNAL,
I'M JUST TIRED OF BEING -- I'M
TIRED OF THE GOVERNMENT TELLING
ME IT IS RAINING.
>> Tucker: I AGREE WITH THAT.
YOU DON'T NEED TO BE A
METEOROLOGIST AND KNOW WHEN YOU
ARE BEING TINKLED ON, I WOULD
SAY.
[LAUGHTER]
WHAT IS THE RESPONSE HERE?
AS YOU WATCH THE CITY COUNCIL
MEMBERS COME A LITTLE BIT OF
CONTEMPT BECAUSE THEY SHOULD
KNOW THIS IS -- THEY ARE BEING
PLAYED, BUT YOU ALSO FEEL A
LITTLE SORRY -- WHAT ARE THEY
SAY TO YOU?
>> THAT IS THE THING.
WHEN YOU GO TO THESE MEETINGS
COME A LOT OF TIMES PEOPLE ARE
NERVOUS AT THE PODIUM.
PEOPLE TALKING ABOUT HOW THEIR
NEIGHBORS HOUSE CAUGHT ON
FIRE -- PEOPLE ARE NERVOUS BUT
WHAT I TRIED TO DO IS PUT THE
HEAT ON THEM.
I WANT TO MAKE THE POLITICIANS
NERVOUS OF WHAT I'M GOING TO DO.
THE REASON WHY AS YOU GO OUT
THERE AND ALL DAY LONG THE NEWS
IS GOING TO TELL US ABOUT THE
BORDER BETWEEN UKRAINE AND
RUSSIA.
BUT I'M IN DALLAS, TEXAS, AND
THE BORDER RIGHT NOW IT'S JUST
BEEN FLOODED WITH
SEX TRAFFICKING, WITH CHINESE
FAT AND ALL -- I'VE HAD FRIENDS
AND FAMILY DIE OF BEER THE REAL
WAR IS RIGHT HERE IN AMERICA.
THIS BIDEN ADMINISTRATION WANTS
TO JUST CONFUSE US AND MAKE US
THINK THAT IT IS A VALID EXCUSE
TO GO FIGHT WORLD WAR III, YET
THE MILITARY-INDUSTRIAL COMPLEX
JUST LOST A 20 YEAR WAR IN
AFGHANISTAN AND NOW THEY ARE
CHOMPING AT THE BIT BECAUSE --
OUR COUNTRY IS NOT BEING RUN BY
HUMAN BEINGS, IT IS BEING RUN BY
AND MIGHT AND NATIONAL
CORPORATIONS THAT WANT TO
DESTABILIZE AMERICA IN ORDER TO
GAIN A GLOBAL CONTROL.
THAT IS WHAT'S HAPPENING.
LOOK AT THESE COMPANIES DOES SHE
LOOK AT ALL THESE COMPANIES THAT
ARE DESTROYING AMERICA ON
PURPOSE IN MY OPINION.
>> Tucker: YOU ARE NOT GOING
TO BE ON YOUTUBE LONG,
OBVIOUSLY.
>> NO, I'M NOT!
>> Tucker: SO IF YOU WANT TO
CATCH THE RT CZAR TO CREATE IT,
DO SO NOW APPEARED THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US TONIGHT.
ALEX STEIN.
>> ONE LESS THING.
EVERYBODY SAYS I'M BABY TALKER,
SO IF YOU ARE WILLING TO SUBMIT
TO PROVE YOU ARE NOT MY FATHER,
BECAUSE WE ARE BOTH GOOD
LOOKING, WE ARE BOTH FUNNY, WE
MIGHT BE RELATED.
YOU ARE MY HERO.
>> Tucker: I DON'T LIK